[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia afecta a los cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza y hacinamiento o
de marginalidad o se veían obligadas a
migrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo comenzamos en kenia país de
áfrica oriental a donde una mujer
ugandesa llegó luego de escapar a los 7
años por un conflicto en su país natal
actualmente es instructora de yoga y
gracias a las plataformas de zoom y
facebook enseña esta práctica milenaria
a refugiados como ella que se encuentran
aislados en campamentos por las
cuarentenas del coronavirus su objetivo
es despertar la autoestima y aliviar la
salud mental de estas personas esta es
la historia
el bailarín el árbol y otras variaciones
de línea son un tipo de yoga de la india
que combina diferentes posiciones del
cuerpo llamadas asanas con respiraciones
acompasadas el yoga es para todas las
edades el yoga es para todos los tamaños
de cuerpo el yoga es para todos el yoga
le cambió la vida a rita brown una joven
ugandesa que tuvo que huir de su país a
los 7 años por un conflicto entre un
grupo rebelde y la comunidad local
solía pensar que no era amada solía
pensar que todo lo que pasó fue como un
destino que dios había planeado para mí
que iba a sufrir por el resto de mi vida
pero desde que me uní al yoga mental
espiritual y emocionalmente sentir
realmente que me cambio
luego de participar en el proyecto de
yoga para áfrica de 2019
rita comenzó a ofrecer clases a
refugiados y trabajadores humanitarios
del campamento kakuma en kenia al fin
laica vienen al campo son venías
sentí que estar en un campamento durante
tantos años es tan traumatizante para un
niño una madre y un padre cualquiera que
viva en un campamento
en el alma estoy dando todas mis fuerzas
todo de mí para cambiar la vida de
alguien que ha sufrido o que está
sufriendo de la iniciativa de rita está
en concordancia con la agencia para los
refugiados de las naciones unidas el
yoga como práctica para mejorar el
bienestar social aliviar trastornos de
sueño y aminorar síntomas de depresión
encuentras que hay tanta gente a la cual
acompañar hay tanta gente a la cual
atender hay tanta gente a la cual
defender especialmente cuando se trata
de problemas de salud mental y
psicosocial es que sabemos incluso que
con el coi 19 ese número ha aumentado la
cobra el perro que mira hacia abajo son
algunas de las posiciones con que rita
instruye a sus alumnos para sacarlos de
la rutina y de sus propios pensamientos
se trata de tu forma de pensar y de cómo
lo tomas porque si eres positivo todo
será positivo
con el yoga voluntaria es como rita
ayudan a cientos de personas para
aliviar su salud mental pero con cerca
de 200.000 residentes en este campamento
de kenia la oferta de ayuda psicológica
se queda corta de manera que la agencia
para los refugiados de las naciones
unidas- busca más fondos con que suplir
esta falencia
[Aplausos]
del yoga pasamos a las técnicas de
defensa personal y de áfrica viajamos a
europa específicamente a estrasburgo
ciudad al norte de francia allí una
asociación de boxeo femenino alienta a
las mujeres a tomar clases de defensa
personal para contrarrestar las
agresiones y los insultos sexistas la
mayoría de ellas ya han sufrido acosos y
los han denunciado ante las autoridades
veamos cerca de 40 mujeres se reúnen los
domingos en este gimnasio de estrasburgo
la mayoría son jóvenes de quienes en
tiempos de pandemia se cubren con
mascarillas y portan guantes sanitarios
hace 19 meses fui agredida violentamente
y había venido aquí por primera vez dos
semanas después de mi agresión pero no
me sentí muy preparada para continuar
con el impulso porque todavía estaba muy
frágil física y psicológicamente y luego
año y medio después habiendo pasado el
juicio con mi denuncia por fin gané y me
siento preparada de nuevo para afrontar
el mundo entre comillas
estas mujeres depositan su confianza en
ivette palatino una entrenadora de 61
años campeona francesa de boxeo
británico y campeona mundial de
kickboxing
por supuesto que ahora las chicas hablan
de eso mucho más que antes pero todavía
hay muchas más agresiones de las que no
había antes especialmente cuando
hablamos de acoso verbal acoso callejero
acoso en el metro quizás también había
en ese momento pero no tanto simpática
en 2013 palatino puso a rodar estos
talleres para la prevención de la
violencia de tener entre 6 y 7
participantes alcanzó a tener 160 antes
de la pandemia de kobe mujeres que
muchas veces denuncian no contar con el
apoyo de la gente a su alrededor cuando
ocurren los acosos
hace dos semanas cuando estaba de
compras me perseguía un hombre afuera de
la tienda y más me siguió adentro me
siguió fuera me siguió en el automóvil
después y de repente ahora quiero poder
defenderme si es necesario
una revista doblada puede ser un arma de
contraataque esta es una de las técnicas
que aprenden esas mujeres mujeres
determinadas a actuar en medio de un
episodio de peligro
vamos a medio oriente a 20 km al sur de
tel aviv en israel un prisionero
palestino se encuentra en un estado
grave de salud luego de más de 80 días
de huelga de hambre
su arresto denominado detención
administrativa pero sin cargos al ud
presuntamente a una relación con un
grupo militante islámico manera lacra se
exige que sea liberado por los israelíes
de inmediato en medio de un consumo
estrictamente de agua
las condiciones de salud del palestino
mayer a lacras están llegando a un
límite desde que lo arrestaron las
autoridades israelíes en julio motivo
que lo impulsó a ponerse en huelga de
hambre mujer solo ha podido ver ciertos
días a su esposa se siente inconsciente
de vez en cuando su estado de salud se
deteriora continuamente y durante los
últimos 40 días no ha podido moverse de
la cama en las calles de ramala en
cisjordania manifestantes protestan por
la liberación de mujer rechazan la
implicación con la que la agencia de
seguridad israelí shin bet lo culpa
participar de un operativo del grupo
militante de la yihad islámica hago un
llamado a la gente en el mundo quien
pueda ayudar a mayer por favor háganlo
quien pueda salvarlo por el amor de dios
salven los aquellos que temen a dios por
favor salven los desde el hospital en
que se encuentra mujer hizo saber que
seguirá en huelga de hambre hasta no ser
liberado a sabiendas de que la corte
suprema de israel no extendió su
detención de cuatro meses que termina el
26 de noviembre
advertimos al enemigo sionista que se ha
obstinado y discriminatorio que debe
liberar a manera lacras quien está
detenido injusta e injustificadamente y
sin ningún cargo por lo tanto exigimos
su liberación para que no sufra daños
dios no lo quiera y si será dañado el
enemigo sionista será considerado
responsable y habrá ramificaciones
peligrosas en la región en israel
existen alrededor de 5000 palestinos en
cárceles de los cuales 350 son como
mayer personas detenidas sin cargos en
su contra según los oficiales israelíes
estos arrestos sin procesos legales son
necesarios algunas veces para proteger
el curso de operativos secretos
hablemos ahora de kobe 19 en mianmar un
núcleo familiar que se contagió de
coronavirus atravesó la cuarentena con
una mujer de 100 años la abuela pasó dos
semanas aislada de sus hijos y sus
nietos pero dijo no haber sentido
síntomas pese al test positivo de las
más de 30 mil personas que se han
contagiado en este país del sudeste
asiático cerca de 700 han muerto aquí la
historia a sus 100 años taking una mujer
mi hermana dio positivo por hobby 19 a
comienzos de septiembre me dijeron que
estaba infectada por este virus pero yo
dije que no sentía nada estaba comiendo
bien duchándome y caminando con
normalidad
si sufriera de este virus estaría
acostada y gimiendo en la cama pero
estuve fuerte y caminando la cuarentena
no sentí nada
tintín fue una paciente asintomática de
coronavirus su familia integrada por
nueve personas más incluyendo niños
también resultó contagiada y sin
presentar síntomas
aún así permanecieron dos semanas de
cuarentena en yangón
tu día que vas de garachiné a toros
guarda la situación durante la segunda
guerra mundial fue mucho peor escuche
que esta pandemia de virus también es
peligrosa en todo el mundo pero siento
que esta enfermedad no es nada por
supuesto estoy preocupada por mis hijos
pero yo he escapado de muchas
situaciones mortales peores y peligrosas
en mi vida me han rescatado de las
bombas y del hambre por eso nada es
importante para mí pero estoy realmente
preocupada por los niños de la próxima
generación
aunque la familia de kim obtuvo luz
verde de los médicos para salir del
confinamiento y luego de dos pruebas en
que todos vieron negativo la nieta de
kim está promoviendo una cuarentena
voluntaria para evitar un re contagio a
pesar de que toda la familia regresó a
casa sana y salva todavía tenemos mucho
miedo de infectarnos de nuevo por eso
nos salimos a ningún lado incluso cuando
tenemos la libertad de ir al mercado
todavía compramos suficiente comida para
días y solo para estar seguros nos
encerramos
o sí
me han mar ha registrado más de 30.000
casos de coronavirus entre los cuales
cerca de 700 personas han muerto de
acuerdo con las autoridades sanitarias
birmanas este país del sudeste asiático
aún no ha logrado aplanar la curva de
contagios
vamos a bolivia a la ciudad de la paz
donde varias mujeres han preferido
recientemente dar a luz a sus hijos al
interior de sus hogares debido a la
saturación de hospitales por pacientes
de kobe 19 es el caso de irma arancibia
quien su séptimo hijo lo parió en casa
contrario a los primeros seis que los
tuvo en hospitales públicos el parto en
casa es asistido por una de las 200
parteras certificadas en bolivia
estas parteras apenas realizaban dos
partos al mes antes de la pandemia pero
ahora cada una realiza una media de 15
partos al mes
antes eran más las manos y más
informados así como que ya habían
elegido conscientemente un parto en casa
y ahora hay mucho que muchos que eligen
por el miedo de ir al hospital hay
algunos que llaman con la anticipación
digamos cuando están de ocho meses algo
así y hay otros que llaman en ese mismo
momento cuando están con el trabajo de
parto este es el panorama a los más
vulnerables de esta semana en el mundo
ante el coronavirus organismos
internacionales y gobiernos están
entregando paquetes de ayuda pero son
miles de millones las personas que
enfrentan esta pandemia en frágiles
condiciones y el alivio sólo es relativo
gracias por seguirnos recuerden que más
información la pueden encontrar en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]